China's government has revealed a new
Crackdown on businesses from the U.S and
other countries offices of three U.S
consulting firms in China have been
rated in recent weeks under a powerful
new security law at the same time
billionaire CEO Elon Musk and other U.S
Business Leaders have been visiting
China to show their commitment to
expanding there Elizabeth Palmer looks
at the new risks of doing business in
China
good morning it's a stressful time for
foreign businesses in China especially
with the state of U.S China relations
being at such low ebb
out of the blue in early May police
showed up at cap Vision a consulting
firm with offices in New York and
Shanghai they searched the premises and
questioned employees
two American firms Bain and Company and
mints group were rated to the business
of all three gathering information for
U.S investors on Chinese companies
after the cap Vision raid Chinese State
tv even aired a special report alleging
with no hard evidence that the company
had lured Chinese citizens to spill
State Secrets this one it said got six
years cap Vision kept its response
low-key it would review its practices it
said with direction from security
authorities
but James Zimmerman a lawyer working in
Beijing says the raids have foreign
businesses spooked everything's a threat
you know and unfortunately in that kind
of environment it very it's very
difficult to operate when everything is
viewed as a national security matter it
looks as if anything you do could be
considered to be spying probably Elon
Musk not only had an audience with
senior Chinese officials during his
visit he got a rapture's welcome from
Tesla employees in Shanghai
and other really big players in China
like apple and Starbucks may be
Untouchable but smaller ones are very
worried a lot of folks are starting to
you know rewrite their strategic plans
just because the attention makes it
politically very risky for them
paradoxically China is actually
encouraging new foreign business right
now but a lot of investors have cold
feet there's a new counter Espionage law
due to come into effect in the next few
weeks and they worry that it will be
weaponized to Target them
for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in
Tokyo